con la punta de sus espadas estas
mujeres combaten a un enemigo común el
cáncer de mama algunas se encuentran en
remisión y otras están atravesando la
quimioterapia como natalie quien fue
diagnosticada en marzo pasado
de fútbol de jong y la esgrima es una
buena actividad para desahogarse y
descargarse a menudo asociamos al
enemigo invisible frente a nuestra
espada con el cáncer con nuestras
espadas lo perseguimos lo matamos y lo
destruimos en millones de pedazos oval y
extrusión iguazú la mayoría de las
participantes conservan importantes
secuelas de sus operaciones la esgrima
les ayuda a recuperar la fuerza en los
brazos especialmente junto a sus
cicatrices
[Música]
para este fin la entrenadora ha sido
especialmente formada para esta terapia
post cáncer trabajamos en el lado que
fue operado eso significa que una mujer
que es diestra y fue operada en su lado
izquierdo debe trabajar en su lado
izquierdo
si ella fue operada en ambos lados debe
trabajar en ambos lados trabajamos sobre
todo en gestos hacia arriba lo que les
permite elevar un poco más el brazo y
recuperar la movilidad que por la
cirugía numerosos estudios científicos
se prueban que la actividad física
regular permite disminuir el riesgo de
recurrencia del cáncer de mama en un 25%
y de mejorar las tasas de supervivencia
en un 30% martín ha sido diagnosticada
dos veces en 2007 y 2019 desde que
empezó a practicar esgrima ha constatado
mejoras importantes en su salud
recupere el movimiento de mi brazo
derecho gracias a los ejercicios que
hacemos llegamos a las clases cansadas y
nos vamos llenas de energía una práctica
para luchar contra la enfermedad pero
también para devolver a estas mujeres en
la moral y el deseo de luchar